Hey Suzanne what you doing?
I'm trying to win this game Dungeons and Dice Monsters.
But they have all these six-sided dice and it needs eight-sided,
10-sided, and 20-sided to play.
Would it be really cool to have a Java program that does all these dice rolling for us?
We could have a different function for each number of sides,
like a function for six-sided dice and another for an eight-sided dice and so on.
Well, we could write a different dice function for each kind of dice.
But the code inside each function would have pretty much the same math.
It's just that the range of the dice roll would change from one through six,
to one through eight, 10, and so on.
Yeah, it's definitely easiest to use
the same function and give it the number of side it needs every time.
Then it could give us the correct range.
Providing the number of sides sounds like a job for parameters.
Let's use the power of input and output to improve our rollDice function.